this is very exciting but also a little
bit depressing because it's not going to
pass the senate
house and senate democrats have
introduced legislation
to make washington dc a state the 51st
state of the united states this is
something we've been talking about for
months and months
the measure was reintroduced in the
house by a delegate eleanor
holmes norton she's a democrat who
represents the district of columbia
and the senate version was introduced by
senator tom
carper from delaware as of tuesday
evening
norton says she has more than 200
co-sponsors
in the house but it appears as though
there is no chance whatsoever
that this is going to pass in the senate
um
democrats control the senate with the
50-50 split and kamala harris as a
tie-breaking vote
but democrats would need to overcome a
filibuster on this issue which requires
60 votes this is not something you can
pass via budget reconciliation meaning
democrats need to find 10 republicans
willing to vote
yes washington dc should me should be a
state
republican lawmakers for a long time
have opposed washington d.c
statehood as you and i have talked about
before
representation in washington d.c would
likely be overwhelmingly democratic
meaning two additional democratic
senators
and that is not something that
republicans want to see now
of course the reality is that on the
merits this makes obvious sense
even by republican so-called values if
the republican party were actually
principled
this should be a unanimous vote in favor
of washington dc
being a state washington dc is being
taxed
without representation big government
is uh ruling over these
washington d.c folks without them
having a voice if this were utah
that didn't have two senators
republicans would have voted
i don't know decades ago and said oh
utah absolutely must have two senators
but the difference is
utah is very red and washington dc is
very blue
but if the principle here is that people
deserve representation
you're paying taxes why do some
taxpayers
get senate representation and other
taxpayers do not
it is because they know who lives in
washington d.c and they know how
washington dc would vote
and so it's not really about principles
or democracy anymore
uh if you are an american you should
have at least
one member of the house representing you
and two senators
how is this even a debate well it's a
debate
because of the uh false claims of
values and principles when it's
convenient to them for republicans
and abandoning those same principles
when it no longer is convenient
washington dc has more than 100
000 more people living in it than the
entire state of wyoming
okay if washington dc was a state
they would have their own national guard
they could have responded on january 6th
without having to
depend on all of these other players to
say fine fine fine we're going to send
national guard
washington dc is the 20th largest city
in the united states
that's not even the dc metro that's
washington dc
itself they pay federal taxes they pay
local
you know they pay all sorts of taxes but
they have no senators
it is absolutely ridiculous and i
hope that joe biden will actually make
this an issue
there have been questions about uh is
how much of a of an issue is this going
to be for the biden harris
administration
the people of washington dc deserve to
be represented just as much as the
people of other states
we know why republicans aren't for it it
is not for any principle
other than the principle of we are
hypocrites and just do things that favor
our party
that's the only principle that
republicans are
abiding by and adhering to when they say
yeah we don't think washington dc should
be a state now we've talked also about
puerto rico
puerto rico i believe both dc and puerto
rico should be states
if puerto rico wants to be a state of
course um
the difference is politically and again
for me
it's the principle so i don't care about
this it's less clear that
puerto rico would probably not be
unanimously democratic in its
representation uh it's it's
there's a larger conservative contingent
in puerto rico
i would expect that there would probably
be
at least one member of the house that is
a republican that would win in puerto
rico
um senate i don't know but the principle
here
makes me come to no other conclusion
then dc should be a state
puerto rico should be a state now i know
people will say well what about american
samoa what about guam okay let we're
we're dealing with puerto rico and
washington dc right now
send me your thoughts about this what
could convince
10 democr 10 republicans in the senate
to say yeah i will vote for d.c
statehood
let me know your thoughts we'll have
continued coverage of this on our
instagram page
at david pakman show and you can follow
me on instagram as well
at david.pacman one of our sponsors is a
free
mobile game called word forest which
i've been having a great time playing
on my phone there are not a lot of
mobile games that i actually
am into but word forest is one i
actually
enjoy because i feel like it's helping
me keep my mind sharp we need that right
now
it's a word game where you connect
letters in any direction to form
hidden word matches with over 2
000 levels you will never get bored of
playing it was really simple to learn
how to play
because it starts out easy but i've been
loving how it gets more difficult as i
progress but i find that
the whole experience is just relaxing it
doesn't have to be super fast-paced
it's awesome for anyone who loves word
games and has a good vocabulary or wants
to improve it go ahead and put yourself
to the test
it's free just go to the apple or google
store
and search for word forest